non c'est assez gros je n'ai jamais
vu le plus gros
j'ai l'air vraiment
mince
rentre à
la maison
goel
la lumière est merdique de toute façon alors allons-y ouais
jette-lui un coup d'oeil rentrons à
la maison notre nouvelle
maison pour la
nuit va essayer de revenir  ce soir oh
mon Dieu il y a des icebergs là-bas
aussi
tu as
besoin
oh il y a tellement d'oiseaux
ouais
un peu plus ouais juste
là comment
ralentir un peu plus [ __ ] gauche Ralentir
ralentis beaucoup puis une vraie
[ __ ] gauche maximum ici
ouais adorable merci
plus  de ça, tu veux de la glace ici
ouais la
glace au bas de la
falaise
si je pars sur le côté ou euh restons sur le
côté
ok c'est bien continue maintenant
normalement ok
arrête on
parie L c'est vrai, va
pousser pour le
week-end
ok ok tu vas y aller  droite